as many people are looking forward to
traveling for the holidays safety should
be top of Mind before you leave and
securing your home is easier than you
think Jonathan Alvarez with Crime
Stoppers of Southern Nevada and CEO of
protective Force International sees a
spike in burglaries around the holidays
he says convenience is key for thieves
so don't make it easy for them investing
in good lighting throughout your house
will not only assist with the camera
systems if you have them but it also
deters a lot of criminal activity
another option is using inexpensive
lighting that is solar powered Nancy
Cruise Morning has two teenagers she
stresses the importance of being careful
of what you post on social media if
you're getting a new game system it's
not necessarily necessarily something
you want to publicize whether that's
leaving the garbage out right in front
of our house so people know what we
bought or just presenting it on social
media and everyone knows that this is
something you have homeowner Cindy
Kester agrees she keeps her windows
locked sealed and covered so no one can
peek inside for the garage doors set it
so nobody can go by and open it so
there's always a little switch that you
can turn it off and that way nobody else
can use their remote to open up your
garage door I do this every night both
Kester and Alvarez agree you should also
get to know your neighbors so you can
watch out for each other some key advice
from experts it's important to hide and
spread out your jewelry and important
documents instead of keeping it all in
one place Mary Jane beliesza 8 News Now